this is one of the most mysterious
sounds in the
universe a billion years ago two black
holes collided at nearly the speed of
light the violent explosion distorted
the fabric of SpaceTime with ripples
called gravitational waves a
gravitational wave is literally the
stretching and compressing of SpaceTime
um as predicted by Einstein over a 100
years ago because Mass actually bends
SpaceTime and so if Mass Jiggles
SpaceTime Jiggles as well so Einstein
predicted that there should be a way
that gravitational waves exist but he
actually thought that there was no
chance that anyone would ever detect
them because they were so minuscule then
in 2015 scientists at a gravitational
wave Observatory known as ligo had a
breakthrough we have protected
gravitational waves we did
it we were super happy to be in the era
of gravitational
waves gravitational waves travel at the
speed of light and they carry
information about the most extremely
relativistic objects in the universe
including objects like black holes so at
higher frequencies the groundbased
detectors like Lego are doing a great
job of measuring black holes at the
solar mass or maybe 100 solar mass scale
but if you really want to measure the
most massive black holes in the universe
or even just different kinds of
gravitational waves you have to go to
much much lower wavelengths for 15 years
an International Coalition known as
nanograph has been trying to detect
gravitational waves at low frequencies
using a technique called a pulsar timing
array we use some of the largest radio
telescopes in the world to measure a
whole bunch of pulsars and hopefully to
directly detect gravitational waves in
the
universe at the end of it it life a
massive star gravitationally collapses
into its core becoming a neutron star a
teaspoon of neutron star material could
weigh as much as a mountain so it's
incredibly dense some neutron stars
begin rotating rapidly blasting out
beams of radiation these are pulsars the
kinds of pulsars that we use are
rotating as fast as a kitchen blender so
when it's spins that beam might actually
get swung into our line of sight kind of
like a lighthouse and whenever that beam
swings past we measure a radio pulse
gravitational waves can subtly alter the
timing of those pulses a gravitational
wave might come from outside of our
galaxy it will then jostle and wobble
all of the space between the Earth and
the many pulsars that we look at so
we've effectively turned our little
neighborhood of the Milky Way and the
millisecond pulsars in that neighborhood
into one big detector through which
gravitational waves can pass in June
2023 nanograph released its 15-year data
showing compelling evidence for the
background hum of lowf frequency
gravitational waves that pervades our
universe we have strong evidence for the
very first time of what we like to call
The Smoking Gun um of gravitational
waves at this frequency range it looks
like noise almost it looks like a random
signal and yet when we correlate the
signal with another pulsar and another
pulsar and another Pulsar we can pull
out this very distinctive correlation
pattern that we call the Helens and
downs curve and for us it's the
fingerprint of the universe swirling in
lots and lots of gravitational waves and
adding together into this hum that we
measure the most likely source of these
waves are violent collisions of super
massive black holes but physicists are
hopeful for more exotic
possibilities it seems strange to say it
but super massive black holes might be
the most mundane explanation for our
signal we know that most galaxies have
super massive black holes and we know
that galaxies merge but there's zillion
papers that have been put out by
theorists um already that are explaining
this background in terms of like basic
and new physics the kind of Beyond
standard model physics strings or new
types of dark matter all sorts of
possibilities and that would be super
super
exciting in physics one set of laws
holds Court the laws of ther Dynamics
govern the flow of energy in the
universe the first law dictates that
energy cannot be destroyed or created
the second says that as energy is
transferred or transformed more and more
of it is wasted in 2008 Japanese
physicist Masahiro hot published a
protocol that seemed to break both laws
it outlined a feat called quantum
teleportation the quantum equivalent of
conjuring energy out of thin air many
important researchers were looking at it
skeptically like thinking H how is that
really true maybe there a mistake or a
misunderstanding there and it took a
while for for the community to realize
no actually Masahiro is that good and
that clever he's actually finding
something that is there that you've
overlooked and it's so unintuitive that
it took you a while uh to comprehend now
15 years later two independent
experiments have teleported Energy
across Quantum devices showing that
protocol works the results offer a rare
window into the Mysterious World of the
quantum vacuum the lowest energy state
known to physics in our best models that
we have to understand matter at the
quantum level uh turns out that the
matter that we see are excitations of
something called Quantum fields that
basically tells you oh what you see and
the particles that you see in particle
physics are not really little spheres
right those things are excitations of
quantum fields that are everywhere if I
get a magnifying glass and I look at
this tiny amount of the room the quantum
feels still there so the vacuum is full
of motion in a way these constant
fluctuations imbue the vacuum with a
minimum amount of energy known as the
Zer Point Energy a system with this
minimal energy is in the ground state if
you try to extract energy from the
vacuum if you do something let's say
here you try to extract energy on this
side from the vacuum you're not going to
be able to do it you're going to have to
pay a price because anything that you do
to the ground state will excise the
ground state and that will cost you
energy but Hoda's quantum teleportation
protocol unlocks a trick Quantum fields
are entangled meaning that the
fluctuations in one spot tend to match
fluctuations in another spot by
exploiting this connection across space
Hoda's protocol allows information to be
sent without using energy what Masahiro
thought is like okay fine so here's what
we can do we can actually instead of
trying to extract energy here we are
going to measure the FI here here and
write down the information that
measurement cost you energy but now you
generated a bunch of information
classical information that you can write
on a notepad right or or or put on a USB
stick now you send that information over
to the other person so this side of the
room still looks like the vacuum locally
it looks like well nothing happened here
it didn't do anything here so Masahiro
sends the information over to a person
here and that person said aha sure it is
the vacuum what I'm looking at but now I
have information about it because
these two parts happen to be entangled
following Hoda's protocol Martin
Martinez and his team designed an
experiment to teleport information
between two carbon atoms in a Quantum
device first they fired radio pulses at
the atoms putting them into a minimum
energy ground state with entanglement
connecting them then they added a third
atom C and fired a radio pulse at both A
and C measuring A's position and
transferring the
information another pulse aimed at b and
c transmitted the message to b and made
a final
measurement the protocol took just 37
milliseconds to run in the lab if the
energy had traveled over these physical
distances it would have taken a full
second this is how you know if is energy
teleportation because if you see energy
moving faster than the time it would
have taken to get there then you know
the energy never traveled so it's just
the information that enabled it we are
showing that you can do a quantum
teleportation implementation in this
particular setup a nuclear magnetic
resonance lab that every University
would have which means that it opens the
door for applications of the protocol
both in technology and in basic
science 2 years ago the James web Space
Telescope launched to lrange point 2 a
million miles from
Earth since the First Data from the tele
telescope was unveiled the only constant
has been surprise the amount of detail
and sensitivity of that data was just
mindblowing we knew immediately it was
going to be a paradigm shifting
telescope just looking at the
data the new discoveries that were
seeing with jwst have been so
groundbreaking that our predictions are
thrown out the
window in 2023 the telescope's
observations continued to challenge our
understanding of how familiar Cosmic
objects like stars galaxies and black
holes came to be some of the most
groundbreaking results from jwst over
its first year and a half have been the
finding of massive things at Early Times
all of a sudden there's all of these
really bright red objects that were
simply completely invisible in Hubble
these Red Dot are super massive galaxies
conveying signals from the beginning of
the universe and that is surprising
because at Early times we basically
expect all objects to just be colliding
into each other all the time there's
something weird going on in terms of how
objects are forming there are really big
things really early things that are the
size of our Milky Way galaxy now except
a couple hundred million years after the
big bang so instead of having 14 billion
years to form they've had a couple
hundred million we say that Rome wasn't
built in a day um and these galaxies
seem to have been built over a period of
time that's effectively like a day in
Cosmic history and we have no idea how
cosmology dictates that galaxies can
only grow so fast they're limited by gas
in giant Halos that contain dark matter
and that gas forms stars and so we're
fundamentally limited by the process of
star formation that we've come to
understand but when we find these
exceptionally luminous exceptionally
massive systems so early then it
potentially could change the framework
of cosmology
itself the other thing that's been very
surprising is that super massive black
holes also seem to form much much
earlier and in much greater numbers than
we had anticipated there is an
overabundance of black holes that weigh
over a million times the mass of our sun
we have no idea how they formed they
might form before the galaxies do they
might be the seeds from which the
galaxies form the universe is much
weirder than anything that we can dream
up in the coming years astronomers are
hoping to answer open questions about
how super massive black holes galaxies
and the first generation of stars formed
alongside each other in the first few
hundred million years of the
universe the thing we're really looking
for is statistics it's no longer about
single galaxies like this exceptionally
luminous system or this really bizarre
Galaxy that we found we want to find
hundreds and thousands of them and that
can really teach us about the evolution
of how they're built over time the new
discoveries are just tip of the iceberg
and I think the next several years will
be profoundly groundbreaking in terms of
what we're able to uh detect and piece
together in terms of our own Cosmic
history galaxies are the home of all
planets All Stars all black holes all
life we don't know how they form we
don't know why we're here so we really
are hoping to get answers to the
fundamental question
that comprise our Cosmic origin story
how we got here from the beginning of
cosmic time to
[Music]
now